a shouting match erupted in the Senate
over the Republican tax overhaul
Democrat sherrod Brown and Republican
Orrin Hatch argued last night bow-bow
who benefits from the GOP plan the
heated exchange came after Republicans
successfully voted to move the bill to
the Senate floor Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning at the heart of this argument is
new analysis by congressional number
crunchers who find that while the plan
lowers taxes at first it would actually
raise them by 2027 for anyone making
under 75,000 dollars a year when
Republicans are in power the first thing
they want to do is give tax cuts to the
rich that's just what sits in their DNA
it's at the end of the old day Senate
Finance meeting Ohio Democrat sherrod
Browns attack on the new Republican tax
plan got under the skin of Chairman
Orrin Hatch I've been here working my
whole stinking career for people who
don't have a chance and I really resent
anybody saying that I'm just doing this
for the rich give me a break
mr. chair of the public I'm not true I
get kind of sick and tired of it
Democrats say Republicans are rushing
the bill through Congress
they're also upset that the plan
eliminates Obama cares individual
mandate cuts the corporate tax rate to
20% and eliminates Americans ability to
deduct state and local taxes over and
over personally and what you said was
not right that's all I'm saying
I come from the lower middle class
originally we didn't have anything so
don't spew that stuff on me I get a
little tired of that crap I'd like you
personally very much but I'm telling you
this bullcrap that you guys saw it he
really gets old after a while to do it
right at the end of this was just not
right the House passed its tax plan
yesterday and Senate Republicans are
hoping to hold a Senate vote on their
bill right after Thanksgiving they in
Syst that these tax hikes will never
actually happen for low and middle
income earners because Congress will
simply renew some of the provisions in
their plan that are set to expire
charlie thanks Nancy